a neo-nazi attacks a synagogue on
Passover politicians politicize the
tragedy and Avengers endgame is awful we
will examine how the tragedy in San
Diego happened and why our culture no
longer knows how to talk about tragedy
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
awful tragedy that happened on the last
day of Passover at a synagogue in San
Diego it could have been a lot worse
than it was there were a lot of things
that happened providential and personal
that came into play that prevented this
from being a massacre nevertheless
obviously just an awful thing to happen
at an awful time and we will examine why
awful things happen how to respond to
them and how even to talk about them but
first you know about purple matress
purple mattress will feel different than
anything you've ever experienced because
it uses a brand new material that was
developed by an actual rocket scientist
I'm a man of simple tastes I'm easily
satisfied by the very best and that's
what purple mattress is it's not like a
memory foam it's not like an innerspring
it's unique because it's firm and soft
at the same time when I first heard
about this I did not believe it because
it sounds like it can't be true I then
got one of these mattresses and I said I
don't know I'm gonna I'm gonna keep my
old mattress I don't really know about
this I slept on it one night and I
immediately threw out my old mattress I
love this thing it is absolutely
fabulous best bed I've ever slept on it
gives you this zero-gravity like feel it
works for any sleeping position you will
get a 100 night risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return your mattress for a full refund
backed by a 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns free in-home setup
and old mattress removal there's no
reason not to try you're gonna love
purple right now my listeners will get a
free purple pillow with the purchase of
a mattress that's in addition to all the
great free gifts they offer site-wide
just text knowles KO wles
to eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get this free pillow is to text
knowles KO wles to eight four eight
eight eight that is k nowl es to eight
four eight eight eight message and data
rates may apply this attack in San Diego
is a clear example of anti-semitism I
don't use that phrase willy-nilly I
don't use the word racism willy-nilly I
don't even I don't use bigotry
willy-nilly the left has taken these
phrases watered them down to not mean
very much
but the
attack was caused by a guy who
vehemently and irrationally hates Jews
and it gets to a bigger question the
question of theodicy it even it reminded
me there's an old cleric hue poem that
says how odd of God to choose the Jews
this is considered a poetic jibe at
Jewish people and the rejoinder to that
was not out of God Gorem annoy him and
then the more profound a response to
that was but not so odd as those who
choose a Jewish God yet spurn the Jews
and that's what you see in what happened
with this nineteen year old guy who went
in and tried to shoot up this synagogue
what happened exactly in San Diego at
this synagogue shooting you saw the
interaction of two distinct elements you
saw Providence and you saw preparedness
it's the only way to describe how this
tragedy didn't become an even bigger
massacre you have a nineteen year old
white supremacist come in there with an
ar-15 rifle and shoot up this synagogue
he killed one woman he wounded three
people including the rabbi the woman who
was killed was 60 year old Lori Kay and
she wasn't killed accidentally she gave
up her life to shield the rabbi from
bullets the rabbi apparently was trying
to get the children out of the synagogue
this woman was a wife and a mother and
she gave up her life to save the rabbi
and to save these children so this
shooter comes in he's got sunglasses on
the rabbi couldn't see his eyes he says
he couldn't see into his soul and the
and the shooter squares up on the rabbi
with the rifle pulls off a round and
misses he goes wide he ends up shooting
off the rabbi's finger when the rabbi
went lifted up his hands then squares up
gets a better aim on the rabbi pulls the
trigger doesn't fire the gun jams guns
Jan
modern guns jam less than some older
guns what are the odds that this gun
would have jammed after he'd only gotten
off a relatively small number of rounds
hard to imagine hard to imagine the odds
of that he gets one round often and
misses these guns are very easy to aim
but he misses the rabbi and then he
pulls it again in the thing jams at this
point at this point of unmistakable
Providence a combat veteran and an
off-duty border patrol agent comes out
and starts running and yelling at the
shooter and he's got his own gun on him
and then this coward this little gutless
sociopath runs out of the synagogue but
he can't stand up to a real guy with a
gun no no he thought he had a soft
target then this combat veteran comes up
with his gun and the guy goes running
now the combat veteran was able to hit
the shooters vehicle wasn't able to hit
the shooter himself the central story
here this guy could have slaughtered
that whole synagogue if not for an
off-duty Border Patrol agent combat
veteran and Providence those two things
if his gun hadn't jammed eventually he
would have fixed the jammer he would
have thrown in a new magazine and if
this good guy with a gun were not here
we wouldn't be talking about one killed
three wounded we'd be talking about a
slaughter at this synagogue Providence
and preparedness
so how our politicians reacting to this
Ilan Omar tweets out famously
anti-semitic congresswoman Ilan Omar
tweets out love is the answer love is
the way and yes less gun
hashtag no more thoughts and prayers is
there any better way to describe the
left in 2019 than the statement no more
thoughts and prayers that's it that sums
up the entire left-wing agenda no more
thoughts no more prayers that's what
they do notice not a terribly specific
statement is it love is the answer love
is the way and no more
guns less guns what are you talking
about if that off-duty Border Patrol
agent hadn't been permitted to carry a
gun the whole synagogue would have been
massacred the whole thing would have
been shot up it doesn't make any sense
and by the way this was expected the
rabbi apparently was so afraid of an
attack on his synagogue that he asked
that off-duty Border Patrol agent to
carry a gun when this guy is starting to
come back into his Jewish faith he asked
him to please carry a gun
I think the rabbi got a permit to carry
a gun though he didn't have one on him
at the time and fortunately he prevented
what could have been much wider killing
no more prayers no more prayers is what
she says prayer is the central issue the
shooter attacked these people while they
were praying the shooter attacked these
people on a holy day that celebrates
God's gift to the Jewish people of
escaping from Egypt of leaving Egypt and
becoming their own nation free nation
the shooter hated those prayers that
these shooters who go in hate prayers
when you come out against prayers as
some people are doing on the left and in
politics you've lost the narrative the
two opposed thoughts and prayers tells
you the whole story now after this
tragedy President Trump calls the rabbi
of the synagogue Rabbi Israel Goldstein
and he explains his gratitude for
receiving this phone call I received a
personal phone call from our president
Donald Trump I was amazed to answer the
phone and say the Secretary of the White
House is calling and he spent close to
10-15 minutes with me on the phone I
mean it's the first time I've ever
spoken to a president United States of
America he shared it because the old sis
on behalf of the United States of
America and we spoke about the moment of
silence and he spoke about his love of
peace and Judaism and Israel and he was
just so comforting that I'm really
grateful to our president for taking a
good time and
and making that effort to share with us
is comfort and consolation I've noticed
this among a lot of my Orthodox Jewish
friends just anecdotally is they tend to
really like Donald Trump for a few
reasons Donald Trump has the most moral
clarity on the question of Israel
Palestine of any president in modern
American history
this is why Israel named that a train
station after him this is why they're
naming a town after him now a Trump also
is clearly I think the most Jew at Pro
Jewish president ever in American
history he's the most nearly Jewish
president himself he's got a daughter
who's a convert to Judaism and he's got
a son-in-law who is in a Jew an Orthodox
Jew this is apparently one of the
reasons why the shooter hates Trump so
the question is why did he do it why did
this 19 year old kid become radicalized
and go in and shoot up a synagogue
sometimes people say who cares their
motivations don't read the manifesto
don't read the notes don't figure out
why you did it he's a lunatic he's a
crazy person it should be dismissed and
he shouldn't get any publicity okay I'm
sympathetic to some of those arguments
but unless you confront the motivations
you're gonna have a harder time
preventing these things in the future
you're gonna have a harder time refuting
these arguments because this guy wasn't
just some lunatic there's no reason to
believe that he has a mental illness or
that he's completely insane
he had a perverse ideology as a perverse
understanding of history and theology
and philosophy so why did he do it the
first thing to know this is a total
copycat of New Zealand it's a total
copycat of that New Zealand shooting not
just in the act of it but in the
manifesto I read the manifesto it looks
exactly like it the it's a copy kind of
not actually not just the document but
the reasons to so this guy the shooter
opens up his manifesto which was
available online I don't know if you can
still find it he opens it up talking
about ancestry and race and blood it's
the first paragraph or two paragraphs of
this thing I'm proud of my ancestry I'm
proud of the blood that
through my veins I'm a descendant of
this person and I have his blood running
through me and that's what matters now
he later tries to justify these crimes
with culture and religion but you'll
notice he doesn't open up the manifesto
on culture or religion he says later in
the manifesto that he's a devout
Protestant Christian well you don't see
that in the first paragraph do you now
he gives away the whole game he is
interested in race he everything else
that goes on top of this racial reason
he's window dressing everything on top
of racial bigotry is a distraction from
the core question so why does he hate
the Jews because he blames the Jews for
everything that has ever gone wrong he
blames the Jews for pornography he
blames the Jews for political
revolutions he blames the Jews for
everything genocide slavery he also says
this is payback for the Jews killing
Christ he puts that in one of the
paragraphs of his manifesto which means
he probably missed the point of the
Gospel story you know we just celebrated
Easter a week ago and the the
crucifixion of Christ is where Christ
conquers death and redeems mankind so
this is why this is why you sing on
Easter Sunday Christian's sing oh happy
fault that one for us so great so
glorious a redeemer and they're talking
about not just the crucifixion all the
way back to the original sin of Adam
it's a way to view the the crucifixion
as not just this very sad moment but
this triumph over death on the cross to
view even that original sin as not this
sad awful tragedy that has no happy
ending but as a tragedy that actually
wins for us a wonderful victory that
actually turns a tragedy into a comedy
he doesn't seem to understand that this
kid and like this New Zealand shooter
this guy in San Diego clearly spent an
inordinate amount of time on the
internet in the deepest bowels of the
internet he dedicates the shooting and
the manifesto to all these anonymous
people on internet
messageboards he uses internet
e-language sometimes he tells jokes that
are ironic so if you're not familiar
with this kind of language you won't
really understand exactly what he's
saying a lot of in references and then
he gets to a direct copycat of that New
Zealand shooters manifesto which is he
does a little interview with himself to
explain his political views so his first
question is are you a Trump supporter
his response you mean that Zionist Jew
loving anti-white traitorous expletive
don't make me laugh so he hates Trump
calls him a traitor and he he hates
Trump because Trump doesn't hate the
Jews we've heard now for weeks then well
really for two years but the mainstream
media certainly for the past few weeks
have been calling Trump a neo-nazi
saying that he called neo-nazis very
fine people clearly the neo-nazis don't
think that Donald Trump likes them very
much I mean the the stated reason why he
hates Donald Trump is that Donald Trump
is not a neo-nazi that Donald Trump
doesn't like neo-nazis that Donald Trump
is too nice to the Jews he then asks
himself are you affiliated with any
political ideology he says yes
it's called not wanting to go extinct so
this is the same exact ideology that the
New Zealand shooter was talking about
it's this idea that white people are
about to disappear and they're all gone
and it's this massive conspiracy by any
number of people it's it's either the
Muslims fault or the Jews fault or the
these people's fault or they're these
pits but it's never your own fault by
the way
nobody ever takes responsibility for
your own problems no no it's always
somebody else's fault and then finally
he says are you a conservative and this
this guy says I'm not a useless
spineless coward so no I'm not a
conservative conservative is a misnomer
they can serve nothing so he he hates
Donald Trump he hates conservatives and
his only political ideology is
essentially racial notice here he's not
really talking very much about his
religious views he's just talking about
race
now you can read the rest of this
manifesto if you want it's just
boilerplate shallow white supremacist
ideology so I wouldn't waste your time
but if you want to you can probably find
it online immediately in the wake of
these things anything that you do is
considered politicizing the tragedy
almost any any way that you can respond
other than saying we're praying for the
victims and we're praying for everybody
involved is considered politicizing the
tragedy and both sides accuse each other
of politicizing the tragedy and
generally speaking politicizing the
tragedy is mostly nonsense why is that
because what is politics politics is
just the way that you and I interact
with each other in civil society
politics is the way that we all get
along underneath the same government so
virtually any way you respond could be
accused of politicizing a tragedy it's
the same kind of phrase when you hear
people say we can't legislate morality
that's another one of these mostly
meaningless phrases listen I just
believe we shouldn't legislate morality
all legislation touches on some aspect
of morality the law exists to codify
some aspect of the moral law this is
obviously true of health care all the
arguments for health care are it's evil
to let people die in the streets it's
evil to not let certain people go get
medical treatment for free it's evil not
to pay for people's cosmetic surgery
it's it's all moral arguments this is
true even of taxes the arguments for
raising taxes are it's wrong it's unfair
you're not paying your fair share or
conversely we need to lower taxes
because I have a right to my Liberty I
have a right to my property it's my
natural right from the natural law this
is morality baby every aspect of the law
has to do with morality and almost any
interaction that we have each other in
some way touches on politics now that
doesn't mean that there are an
inappropriate ways to respond to a
tragedy there are appropriate ways and
there are inappropriate ways
and one of them by the way is Alexandria
Ocasio cortezes so she tweets out right
right after this happens quote
heartbroken to hear of the San Diego
synagogue shooting particularly so on
this final day of Passover we have a
responsibility to love to protect our
neighbors the longer the Senate delay is
holding a vote on HR 8 the more we put
Americans at risk
what heartbroken to hear about this we
should protect our neighbors if you
don't vote for the very specific gun
control legislation that I want you to
vote for you are basically responsible
for shooting up a synagogue that's an
inappropriate way to respond to a
tragedy inappropriate way to respond to
a shooting in part because it's just not
true
HR 8 is some more gun control
legislation to expand background checks
no evidence whatsoever that this would
have prevented this shooter from getting
a gun no evidence whatsoever that this
would have prevented any of the other
mass shootings that we have seen in
recent years so we asked ourselves how
could we have prevented this shooting
how could we have stopped this more gun
control no there's no evidence that any
major gun control law that's been
proposed would have stopped any of these
things how about if law enforcement had
somehow caught this guy earlier I guess
that would have stopped it but how would
they have caught the guy the guy who did
it had no prior contact with law
enforcement the guy before that but
before this shooting happened he was
basically a model citizen wasn't
arrested he didn't have any priors
well maybe if we were able to catch
mental illnesses earlier again there's
no evidence this guy has a mental
illness when you read that manifesto
it's perverse but it's not insane it's a
perverse ideology that he's following
down to its own logical conclusions but
it's not the ravings of a lunatic it's
the ravings of a bigot who's filled with
hatred who becomes violent none of those
precautions would have prevented this
shooting or any other none of them
fortunately the shooting was prevented
from becoming much much worse one person
dead
it's a tragedy it's less tragic than had
the entire congregation been killed how
did how was that prevented Providence
and preparedness a gun jamming at
exactly the right time and a guy who was
carrying a gun the the greatest most
obvious evidence that gun control would
not have prevented the shooting more gun
control may have made the shooting a lot
worse what does it all boil down to is
it's hard for us to accept that evil
exists how odd of God how odd of God
that in this creation of ours there's
evil and suffering and it's not just
evil and suffering for people who make
bad decisions it's evil and suffering
for innocent people one of the people
who was shot at this synagogue was a
little girl was shot in the leg I think
she was eight years old this 60 year old
woman gave her life to save her rabbi
totally innocent another man that little
girl's uncle shot innocent why do bad
things happen to good people
why does a little kid get leukemia how
odd of God how do we accept tragedy the
reason that we can't have a coherent
political conversation about this
actually we can't have a coherent
cultural conversation about this we
can't have a coherent cultural
conversation because we cannot have a
coherent religious conversation it's not
just that there are attacks on
synagogues there was obviously there was
the attack on the mosque in New Zealand
obviously there have been countless
attacks and desecrations of churches
throughout France and throughout the
West there was another attack that just
occurred on a Protestant Church in
Africa five people killed including the
pastor of that church there is an attack
broadly on religion and it's really too
bad because the only way that we
and understand this tragedy is religion
this is the question we live in a fallen
world and all we want to do is perfect
it all we want to do is say oh just one
more law one little bit of money just
one tweak to the regulatory state and
then no more tragedies no that's not how
it works no government program will end
evil and so we can't accept the tragic
fact of life ironically then we can't
accept the fact that justice exists if
we can say right now with a good deal of
certainty there's really nothing we
could have done but as a society before
this shooting to stop it
what about afterward is there some
justice that we can have now
unfortunately in the state of California
about a month ago governor Gavin Newsom
put a moratorium on the death penalty
the the dog who shot up that synagogue
should be taken out back and killed by
the state by the civil authority the
state should execute him he should die
he should die because that is just and
that will give us some modicum of
justice it is important because it can
deter other shooters it is important
because he deserves it because it is
punishment because he committed a crime
and that demands retribution but we
don't understand the tragic fact of life
and so we don't understand justice
either we think there's some way to fix
it some way to just make it all better
no we can now though at this moment we
can enact justice by putting down this
killer like the dog he is to claim some
modicum of justice we can't do that
though can we you know speaking of
alexandria cassio cortez she's she's in
trouble again because she came out and
she used this tragedy to try to push
around gun control legislation and then
it was pointed out she never said
anything about the Sri Lanka Church
attack killed 300
on Easter Sunday 300 people and she she
never made a statement about it
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez tweeting 25
hours a day and so Kelly and Conway goes
out on television and says it's a little
weird that she doesn't talk about this
and Ocasio Cortez responds hello MS
Conway on Easter I was away from tech
visiting my grandmother in Puerto Rico
which continues to suffer from the White
House's incompetent Disaster Response
are you trying to imply that I am less
Christian what's the point of you
bringing this up on national TV the
point is very clear alexandria Ocasio
Cortez is only going to comment on
things that affirm her narrative and the
killing of Christians around the world
does not affirm her narrative doesn't
affirm her narrative on
intersectionality or victimhood or
religious bigotry Christians can never
be the victims according to Ocasio
Cortez and even when she comments on the
synagogue shooting it's just to push her
own legislation that wouldn't have
prevented it and might have made the
shooting worse that's the point that
that Kelly and Conway is making now did
a OC understand this probably not but we
don't understand how to talk about
tragedy either and this becomes apparent
in all of our fiction in all of our
novels in all of our movies including
the biggest movie that came out over the
weekend Avengers endgame the biggest
there were a lot of problems with it I
hate the Marvel movies to begin with but
one of the central problems is we can't
talk about tragedy we have such a
shallow view as a culture about tragedy
we will get to that in a second then
we'll get to a little political wrap-up
because there's a lot of very bad news
for Joe Biden and it's it's worth
talking about because his campaign is
floundering but first got to go to daily
wire.com 2010 bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me at the end
or Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro
show you had to ask questions in the
mailbag you get the mount wall show you
get another Kingdom you get to ask
questions backstage and you get the left
is tears tumblr very important the only
vessel capable of holding all those
salty delicious leftist tears go to
daily wire comm we'll be right back with
a lot more
I saw Avengers and I hated it I'll tell
you all the reasons I hate it at first
but then we'll get to the bigger
cultural problem to begin 3 hours long 3
hours of my life
I have given away to watch this insipid
movie the movie is divided basically
into 4 acts the first act is unbearable
it is so slow and pointless and horribly
written and mostly poorly acted I was
checking my watch every 5 minutes the
second act is bearable
it's nearly tolerable it actually has
one moment that's almost poignant so ok
that part is ok the third act is
inevitable it's the thing that happens
in every superhero movie and then the
fourth act is totally saccharine
sentimental self-indulgent payoff for
all the people who have watched 20 of
these movies certainly not me and so
that was pretty awful to watch to one of
the four acts was almost tolerable the
others were awful what was so bad about
the movie there's no stakes whatsoever
there's there's no stakes at all we
already know from the Marvel Universe
that people can die and come back right
we already know from every superhero
movie that basically everything turns
out the way you expect it to we already
know that these guys have superpowers
and so some of them have superpowers
that are so immense that basically
they're invincible okay that was one
aspect the other is it's tediously
politically correct
the moments of political correctness are
so egregious and cringe-inducing luckily
there aren't too many of them they're
like three or four of them throughout
the movie but you just think oh my gosh
what are you doing to me and and some of
the implications of this political
correctness I'm trying to speak in vague
terms so I don't spoil the movie for
those of you who for some reason want to
go see it but some of the implications
of this political correctness just don't
make any sense at all like are exactly
contrary
two characters characters motivations
and the the worlds that these characters
inhabit in some cases the characters are
just terrible so Captain Marvel is just
a horrible character she's annoying
she has no weaknesses really her biggest
weakness is that when she was eight
years old she got kind of angry
sometimes now she has basically no
weakness she's just a perfect and
amazing can do no wrong this is the one
of the real downsides of injecting
political correctness into superhero
movies is superheroes when they don't
have a weakness become really really
boring really quickly but if you're
making superhero movies for the purpose
of injecting gender politics or leftism
or intersectionality then you basically
can't give them any weaknesses so it's
just totally boring that is Captain
Marvel though I guess the best thing I
could actually say about avengers
endgame is that it's not Captain Marvel
that's that's a good thing and it's not
black panther either it's better than
Black Panther which again damning with
faint praise then there's the saccharine
sentimentality of it all it's just so
nostalgic it's just I get it it's you're
talking about twenty movies here people
have been watching this threat or this
whole course so you kind of want a
little bit of a Clips show you kind of
want to go back and revisit old memories
okay fine but it's so indulgent it's
just that my final takeaway is that
Scarlett Johansson is terrific she is
such a good actress and she's hotter
than a two-dollar pistol so that part
was really good and Robert Downey jr. is
good in it I mean there are some
performances are pretty good the guy who
plays Captain America is awful I get it
that he is a very attractive man and
looks like Captain America I get it
right but his performance is not very
good some of the others are fine or
whatever it's okay take it or leave it
the writing is pretty weak in a lot of
places okay whatever take it or leave it
the biggest issue with the movie
actually does relate to our theme today
how odd of god this problem of evil that
evil exists in the world is the movie is
basically about
how to deal with regret and grief after
some evil action has occurred that's not
a spoiler we know some evil action has
occurred and now all the superheroes are
trying to come to grips with that how
can you change what happened
can you change what happened if you
changed what happened would it change
the future why did it happen why does
evil exist why don't the good guys win
every single time all the time that's a
serious question there's one moment in
act 2 that nearly approaches poignancy
it almost gets to a serious discussion
of this problem and then it totally runs
away from it
it totally backs away and the answer
that Avengers endgame gives for how to
deal with evil is basically lalalalala I
don't know no Nance no it's let's make
it all better and it'll just all be
better and it can be better for some
reason that's basically the answer that
it gives now you might say Michael
you're making too much out of a
superhero movie this is a popcorn movie
for people who like the the funny
costumes and saving big explosions okay
fine that's also true of the Greek myths
that's also true of the Nordic myths
that's also true of the stories that
we've told ourselves for years and years
which were the Greek myths were the
superhero movies of their day and of the
ensuing millennia but those those Greek
myths also told us something about our
nature
good myths good fantasy stories tell us
something about reality and about human
nature and so you've got explosions and
superpowers and monsters and ogres and
Giants and you have all the same
elements as every superhero story but
they tell you something true about your
nature and about reality and about evil
and about God and about our purpose and
why we're here and how we came to be
here now let me ask you something if
you're a defender of the Avengers movies
and the Marvel movies what
profound truth about human nature is
conveyed in these movies what does this
movie tell you about reality suffering
grief evil personality God what does it
tell you about anything that stories are
supposed to tell you about without
giving away any spoilers it tells you
the opposite of the truth that's what it
does it's it's a fantasy in the true
sense of fantasy nothing really has any
stakes probably nothing really has any
costs I guess you know you'll see in the
future movies if anything really has any
costs if you can correct one evil in
history why can't you go back and
correct other evils well because you
just can't if we're so focused on
stopping one evil why not all the evils
why don't we live in a perfect world
why don't we exert our will to just
create a perfect world why is that not
possible
how odd of God to create a world in
which evil exists what does that mean
maybe it means that we live in a world
with freewill why do we live in a world
with freewill
what is our freedom mean how does our
freedom relate to Providence to the
grace of God in the the take away from
that synagogue shooting is Providence
and preparedness the Providence of the
gun jamming the preparedness of the
combat veteran being there to chase the
shooter out of the synagogue save lives
not every life one woman died but he
saved every other life in that room what
does that interaction look like that's
what stories are supposed to help us
deal with and what do we make of the
inevitable tragedy of life in the here
and now once you catch the shooter now
we can't kill him he can't
capital punishment at the founding of
this country the punishment for every
serious crime was death you would hang
for any serious crime that was the
definition of a felony now in many
states you can't die for any crime state
of California if this guy is punished by
the state of California he will not be
killed more than that you have
presidential candidates saying that this
guy should vote Bernie Sanders last week
said that this guy who shot up the
synagogue shooting should not vote just
when he leaves prison he should vote
from prison
that is our cent our talk about justice
these days and why is it why is our talk
about justice so totally warped we've
actually had to create a whole other
term for it because we know that what
we're talking about is not justice so we
call it social justice and social
justice really just means not justice
why it's because if you put garbage in
you get garbage out if you put in a
garbage premise about human nature that
this isn't really a tragic world that we
really can perfect human nature you're
gonna get out the garbage conclusion
that we should never kill anybody that
there's no such thing as real justice
there's only social justice which is all
about therapy and rehabilitation and not
giving up on that stupid garbage premise
in the first place that human nature is
perfectible in this world it's not
that's our moral discourse and so when
you if you accused me of her rang a
popcorn movie like Avengers say you
don't like superhero movies it's true I
hate superhero movies and I especially
hate the Marvel movies
I liked Dark Knight and I liked Logan
but the other ones I can't stand right
okay then I just wouldn't go see them
but the issue is I have to go see them
because superhero movies aren't just
movies for kids anymore they're not even
just movies for kids and for nerds
they're actually movies for every but
they are the central cultural event that
happens in the United States that movie
took in 1.2 billion dollars over the
weekend it's basically the only movie
that people will go see anymore
that's pretty sad that tells us our
culture has been degraded and our moral
language has been degraded and therefore
our politics is going to be degraded we
say don't politicize a tragedy don't
politicize this don't politicize that
sure yeah we shouldn't we shouldn't act
inappropriately but politics is down
from culture culture is down from
religion or cultural or cultural moments
our movies and our books and our
fantasies reflect a religious
understanding and they are reflected in
our politics you can't divorce them real
profound religious misunderstanding and
bigotry is going to be reflected in
certain cultural memes and it's going to
be reflected in awful political actions
terrorist actions it's going to be
represented in in the wicked actions of
individuals to hurt innocent people all
political problems fundamentally
ultimately our religious problems and
culture is right there in the middle of
that and that's why you've got to take
culture seriously even if it's a popcorn
movie with a lot of superheroes before
we go we have got to get to a little bit
of politics because Joe Biden's campaign
has had trouble from the very beginning
I know it looks like he's eight points
up right now not just on the Democrats
but morning consult and Politico say Joe
Biden is up eight points on Donald Trump
don't believe it
Joe Biden is going into this with the
nice glossy I've been out of the public
eye for years I'm the former vice
president under Barack Obama I'm a
really nice guy and I never did anything
controversial in the last four years
okay don't believe it Joe Biden is
already having trouble they obviously
got him on sniffing gait they got him on
all those weird interactions with those
women you know smelling their hair or
giving them shoulder massages now
they're trying to get him on a Nita Hill
which doesn't make any sense they're
trying to get him on the Supreme Court
confirmation hearings of Clarence Thomas
in 1991 and they're saying that Joe
Biden didn't treat Clarence Thomas's
accuser fairly just ridiculous he gave a
knee to Hill the ability to air
all of her claims her claims in many
cases were debunked and Clarence Thomas
got the confirmation if anything Joe
Biden should apologize to Clarence
Thomas not to Anita Hill but now the big
problem is facing is that Barack Obama
won't endorse him and here is the Joe
Biden is mustering for that so he's
being followed by this gaggle of
reporters and he knew that answer was
weak so he had to get out of there
why hasn't Barack Obama endorsed you his
first try is I asked him not to endorse
me now his campaign operatives had been
saying this for the past week oh yeah
Joe asked Obama not to endorse yeah okay
if you believe that I got a great bridge
in Brooklyn to sell you I pay hey
popular former president of my party
that I served under for eight years
please don't endorse me hey I know
there's a field of twenty Democrat
candidates now and it's gonna be really
hard to differentiate yourself I
definitely don't want the popular former
President to endorse me that would be
terrible right so nobody believes this
Joe Biden knows that nobody believes
this so then you hear people are missing
this he changes his answer immediately
after he gives it he says I asked Barack
not to endorse and he doesn't want to he
wants the the people of the Democrat
Party should decide we should the
candidates should win it on their own
merits hold on did you ask him not to
endorse you or does he not want to
endorse obviously
doesn't want to endorse you and you
would take his endorsement but why does
Barack Obama not want to endorse Joe
Biden because he thinks Joe Biden's a
lot weaker then the media think he is
another report just came out that Barack
Obama nudged Joe Biden not to run in
2016 the reason was he thought Hillary
was a stronger candidate why is he not
endorsing Joe Biden now because he
thinks like I am that you Oh Biden is a
pretty weak candidate no matter what the
polls say the polls can never be wrong
right the polls are always right is that
what we learned in 2016
got to trust those polls how could those
polls ever be wrong
especially especially about an election
involving DOM and Trump so it's a this
is a big blow for for Joe Biden we've
been saying this for weeks now the only
way that Joe Biden really is able to
sustain that lead I think is if Obama
comes out strong for him
at the top of the race that has
apparently been closed off we'll see
where Joe goes from here again we've
long said that first day of the race was
gonna be Joe Biden's best day and then
he was just gonna trail you're already
seeing his net favorability dropped five
points since January probably only
headed further down now why why is Joe
Biden no good at this why just Barack
Obama think that Joe Biden ultimately
can't beat Donald Trump that some other
candidate would be better one of the
rumors is that Michelle Obama is going
to get into the race I'm highly
skeptical of that I don't think that is
happening but I do agree with Obama that
he's probably not the strongest
candidate it's because Joe Biden schtick
is being the everyman the popular guy
he's going he's just gonna nuzzle your
little daughter he's a I'm just Joe I'm
a big giant smile hey I'm Joe Biden that
game is a losing game against Donald
Trump because Donald Trump is the most
authentic for better or worse politician
that we've maybe ever had in our history
certainly in the last hundred years I
was the other I was on Jesse Watters a
show on Fox News the other night they
interrupted our segment because Trump
was giving this rally so I watched the
entire rally be
to end Donald Trump is just so good at
politics here's just a quick little clip
of how he opens up his rally by the way
Saturday night is there any place that's
more fun than a Trump rally
can you imagine sleepy Joe crazy Burnie
you look at the candidates right
I think Pocahontas she's finished she's
out she's got
now when it was found that I had more
Indian blood in me than she did and then
it was determined that I had none but I
still had more that was the end of her
32 years scam on colleges Donald Trump
is gonna eat Joe Biden for lunch this is
where he thrives these rallies are where
he thrives he doesn't always thrive in
press conferences he doesn't always
thrive in oval office meetings he
doesn't always thrive from the position
of president but he totally kills it in
these rallies and these rallies are what
campaigns are this is the stuff of
campaign so he had another line he said
you know before I became a politician
can you believe I'm a politician and the
PETA crowd goes crazy they love him they
just eat it up that is the game that Joe
Biden has been trying to play for 40
years he spent 40 years becoming the
slickest politician in Washington to be
slick enough to pretend that he's not a
real politician Oh Joe he's so authentic
that's what makes Joe Joe bs Joe Biden
is a totally constructed politician this
guy is the real thing you put those two
up against one another it's not gonna be
close all right that's our show we got a
lot more to get to but too bad too late
I'll see you tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
nolde show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua Alvaro and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today we're going to talk about this
story of an innocent family being ripped
apart by Child Protective Services
because apparently if you haven't
noticed by now you have no rights and
you have no presumption of innocence
whatsoever when the bureaucrats in CPS
set their sights on you so we'll discuss
that also President Trump got himself
into hot water which he's done many
times but this time when he called
robert e lee a great general well robert
e lee was in fact a great general and it
is absurd that we are not allowed to say
that anymore so we'll talk about that as
well today over on the Matt Walsh show